hey youtubers it's Charlie so I just got
to see Maleficent so this video is gonna
be my review in case you didn't know
Disney is using their giant spinning
wheel to retell the story of Sleeping
Beauty from the perspective of the
villain or at least the person who was
the villain in the original animated
movie because a lot of you probably
haven't seen it yet I'm just gonna do my
non-spoilery review first and then I'll
put it into context with the original
animated movie and then during spoilers
I'll talk about my top 5 moments
specifically if you're just finding me
for the first time though because we're
in the middle of summer movie season and
there's so many big movies coming I'm
just gonna be doing reviews each week be
sure to subscribe to get everything
the next thing that's coming is Fault in
Our Stars that's gonna be next week feel
free to leave me suggestions for any
other movies you think I should do so
let's talk about Maleficent she is
hopefully the beginning of what I think
is a new wave of Disney villain movies
she's let the Iron Man of Disney
Villains she sits way up at the top
naturally it just makes sense that she
would get her own movie first I'll talk
more about the other Disney villains I
think need their own movies after my
review but because this is a villain
movie I wanted to spend most of the
video talking about the characters
because that's why I go see movies the
plot is totally fun but it's Angelina
Jolie and that smile that really made me
excited to go see this movie she was
hypnotizing before Disney used all that
makeup and CG to make her mouth bigger
if you look at her in real life yes she
is famous for those lips but the movie
dials that way up to infinity she can
bite me with those teeth anytime she
wants it's pretty clear going into this
that she's gonna be most people's
favorite thing about this movie and she
was definitely my favorite thing she
just fills that Maleficent role with so
much power that I'm starting to
fantasize about her being on Game of
Thrones is like an alternate reality
version of Cersei Lannister not to say
anything bad about Lina hate she is also
amazing it's just a testament to
Angelina that she can play characters so
well and be a leading lady there's this
weird thing about lead actors in
Hollywood usually lead actors are the
most boring think about it this way
Disney sells parts of the Caribbean
movies on Johnny Depp not Jack Sparrow
so at every point you're sitting in one
of those movies you're thinking you know
this is Johnny Depp being amazing you're
not thinking about Jack Sparrow so much
character actors are different like
Michael Sheen in Twyla
or Tron Legacy you're not thinking about
Michael Sheen when you watch him you're
just thinking about ro the Volturi
orchester his Tron character but that's
why I think Angelina Jolie is so great
because she can disappear into her roles
it makes it so much fun to watch all of
her movies I'll talk more specifically
about her Maleficent character during
spoilers Elle Fanning on the other side
of that equation was also totally
amazing she's actually pretty quickly
becoming one of my new favorite young
actresses because Angelina Jolie drives
the whole movie though Sleeping Beauty
is only a supporting character but she
was still a lot of fun to watch as this
young optimistic princess you know who
doesn't really even know what the word
evil means for most of the movie but
there is this pretty clear issue with
the movie where even though it does kind
of retell this classic Sleeping Beauty
tale in this new complex way almost all
of the characters are pretty close to
what they are in the original movie with
the exception of Maleficent it just
makes it a lot harder for those simpler
characters to stand out but L Fanning's
character Aurora made this amazing foil
for Maleficent it's really their
relationship that drives the plot
forward kind of informs at least the
most important story in my opinion this
would be like a really great movie to
take your mom to go see like it's a
movie about the relationship between
mothers and daughters the only thing I
didn't really like about the movie was
the voiceover and the fact that the
female characters were still heavily
defined by their relationships with the
men in the film like the female
characters were defined in terms of
their romantic relationships with the
men the voiceover I totally understand
it's the Blade Runner argument all over
again in case you never heard about it
there was this controversy with the
movie Blade Runner one of the best
science fiction movies period whenever
the movie was originally released the
studio wanted Ridley Scott to add a
voice over because they felt like we the
people watching it were too dumb to
follow the story so really Scott was
forced to add the voiceover at the end
of the movie and it really hurt the
story in my opinion there was a
director's cut you know way later that
took that voice-over out and the movie
got way better but this is all I could
think about whenever the voice-over was
happening during Maleficent it just
really took me out of the story it's
really there for little kids to help
them follow the movie because that's
really who's gonna go see this movie
more than anyone else little kids so I
understand why they included it I'll
talk a little bit more about my issues
with the female characters
their portrayal in the movie when we get
to spoilers so let's actually just plow
on into that so careful for spoilers if
you haven't seen the movie yet but here
are my top five moments number five
maleficents use of magic everything
about magic in this movie is so much
more fun than Oz you know the last big
live-action Disney movie like this in
the movie Angelina Jolie is the only one
that gets to use magic and it kind of
seems like she's got crazy power that
creates a few issues for the story but
overall just the visual look was amazing
I just love the way they use magic in
this movie number four the three fairy
godmothers the movie twist the use of
fairy godmother but I'm talking about
the three fairies that raised her I
loved the way they turned them into the
Three Stooges it's like they made them
way less nurturing than the original
cartoon versions like they were
babysitters just trying to earn a
paycheck of all the fairies I only
recognize Juno temple but she was in
this other movie called brass teapot
where she basically gets the crap beat
out of her so that money comes out of
this magic teapot and it kind of
reminded me of some of the Three Stooges
gags they did it was just a really
hilarious negative spin on the original
characters like you would definitely not
want to use them as babysitters like
they would be the worst babysitter's in
the world it's really Maleficent in the
movie that is the caretaker and number
three all the big changes from the
original cartoon I'm talking about the
metal vines inside the castle the dragon
and making the King Chardo copeley the
villain there were a lot more things
they change but even if you haven't seen
the original cartoon for a long time the
things that everyone remembers most are
Prince Charming having to get through
the vines at the end and kill the dragon
here's a really big question that you
don't necessarily have to answer in the
comments but if she could turn D vault
into a dragon at any time why didn't she
do it at the beginning and just take her
wings back that way and just destroy the
castle it's kind of like the Lord of the
Rings Griffin's argument you know why
didn't they just ride the Griffins to
Mount Doom in the beginning in their
defense though there would be no movie
if they did it completely logically
number two the Maleficent Aurora
relationship this is like the most
important part of the movie the
evolution of their relationship and how
it changes Maleficent somehow I don't
think she ever hated Aurora even when
she was a little baby like that's the
whole idea of the movie she was never a
villain in the true sense of the word
she keeps saving her life and protecting
her she even tried to undo that curse
halfway through the movie
if only we had the power to take back
the shitty things that we said at least
we can delete tweets though and my
number one moment from the movie so this
is actually a really specific moment but
it's when Maleficent takes Aurora to the
Moors for the first time it's that
moment where Aurora just starts to
explode with happiness and Maleficent
just goes poof and shuts her down like
she's thinking oh my god that's enough
of you she just can't handle all that
pure emotion I feel like if everyone
could have a secret power that would be
it just be able to shut people down
whenever they get too crazy like poof
you be quiet and go to sleep now but now
it's your turn let me know what your
favorite part from the movie was just to
address my issue with the female
characters I think the movie did a real
disservice to Maleficent and particular
just by making her so hung up on
Stephane yes he stole her wings but
she's almost a god she could have just
taken them back at any time it's like
the story forces her to wallow in her
own misery you know like everyone's
awful and love doesn't even exist in all
fairness there was that long montage
that they just glossed over so I'm
assuming that Stefan and Maleficent were
deeply in love and the movie just didn't
show that to us on screen otherwise I
thought it was a great entry into you
know what's hopefully a long line of
brand-new Disney villain movies the next
Disney villain that I really think
should get their own movie is Ursula
from Little Mermaid that would be
amazing if you haven't been watching it
actually Once Upon a Time has been
bringing on a lot of these new
characters like Elsa from frozen onto
the TV show they've already done
Maleficent she was Pam from True Blood
but if you want to see more alternative
spins on Disney characters that would be
a really good show to watch so in
related news next week I'll be doing a
Fault in Our Stars movie review be sure
to subscribe to get it feel free to
leave me suggestions for other movies
you think I should do too but right now
click here for my x-men Days of Future
Passed review and click here to learn
all about the Star Wars boba fett to be
the new one that's happening
thank you so much for watching I'll see
you guys tonight high fives